in a world divided by fear one man must
stand alone against the forces of
darkness from the studio that
inexplicably showed his mouth
shut the first time comes five-time
Academy Award viewer Ryan Reynolds as a
man on an eharmony date with destiny
ladies and gentlemen I give you hey
Deadpool so get ready to blow out your
collective sphincters cuz my trailer is
coming tomorrow
hey youtubers is charlie so they dropped
the teaser for the Deadpool trailer
that's coming tomorrow is a little bit
of Fox poking fun at themselves and a
little bit of Ryan Reynolds poking fun
at himself in addition to making fun of
all the problems they had making the
movie couple years ago the actual
Deadpool movie they're making fun of
Wolverine Origins hardcore so I'm sure
Hugh Jackman has a good sense of humor
and that really wasn't his decision
creatively to so deadpool's mouth shut
so everybody go watch wolverine origins
sometime tonight and think about that
what's gonna happen is his Conan's gonna
play it on TV during his show tomorrow
night and then the probably just posted
online right right after that so i'll be
doing a video just as soon as they
posted online i'm expecting it to be
pretty close to what that comic con
trailer was so i'll put a link to the
video i did for that in the description
just who you guys and I have an idea
like what's in that this is one of those
really rare instances went the studio
makes a movie that the fans really want
and they're totally owning up to the
fact that things just did not work out a
couple years ago but I don't think it
really would have gone down any other
way but I think at the time Deadpool
wasn't a total lock for them just like
the movie that they had intended to make
so it gave him a little bit more time to
work on it I don't know how close this
movie is to the original script I do
know that they changed it quite a bit
but if you run into another Deadpool fan
on the street tomorrow be sure to give
them a high five or buy them a
chimichanga or something because the
hardcore fans are the reason that this
got made I won't say piracy got this
movie made but that thought is in there
somewhere too just because someone
leaked the trailer test that was meant
to be like passed around inside the
studio but that's the kind of footage
they show to executives so that they'll
approve certain things like here's what
the movies gonna look like will you
please green like this so we can make it
big and shiny if fans hadn't gone so
crazy over that last year Comic Con like
not this past comic-con but 2014 then
the studio probably would have
prioritized it so much in the fact that
Ryan Reynolds stayed with the project is
a big deal too because he's at a point
where he can basically do any project
that he wants although it is awesome
that he pokes fun at himself for being
an Academy Award watcher even though
this is going to be a badass movie you
know I'm not thinking so much about its
Academy Award chances it's one of those
movies that like you really want to see
and is a lot of fun so really that's all
that matters I think the people that
actually made the movie will get the
recognition they deserve so even if Ryan
Reynolds doesn't continue to play other
superheroes hopefully he'll
come back to the Deadpool franchise will
see him like every year at comic-con
because their marketing campaign for the
movie was brilliant they were having
some fun on Twitter with each other just
in keeping with the tone of Deadpool but
I'm really excited for you guys to see
the comic con footage it's just going to
the stuff that will be seeing on Tuesday
it will just be a shiny version of what
they showed off in Hall H if you've
never made it inside Hall H a lot of
times what those show is like the work
print stuff so if you know a lot about
the project it really doesn't matter but
out of context it can be kind of weird
but there's a lot of other awesome stuff
happening this week the new Fantastic
Four movies out so i'll be doing a
couple videos for that i'll do some more
bonus videos for Deadpool if there's any
like specific ones you guys want just
let me know in the comments I'm actually
doing a Deadpool giveaway but I wasn't
expecting this like little teaser to
drop so I'm going to double the giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so they'll be like two winners
whenever I post my Deadpool trailer
video tomorrow if you guys want to read
some Deadpool while you wait for the
trailer to drop get Marvel unlimited
they don't have like every single
deadpool comic ever made on it but they
do have a lot of it i actually think i
have enough Deadpool videos to make it's
like own playlist now so i'll just i'll
do that you can click here to learn
about his top five sidekicks in the
movie there's actually a ton of
characters in the movie a bunch of x-men
characters too and you can click here to
learn all about ian mcshane from
deadwood joining Game of Thrones so just
awesome news this weekend lots of
Deadpool lots of Game of Thrones
Fantastic Four's coming thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tomorrow
you